>> ♪ ♪
>> Tucker: THE FIRST BIG UFO
SIGHTING WAS 1947 IN ROSSWELL,
NEW MEXICO.
THERE WAS A BIGGER EVENT ALSO IN
NEW MEXICO AT THE MOMENT THE
U.S. GOVERNMENT DETONATED THE
FIRST AUTOMATIC WEAPON.
WITNESSES ON THE GROUND SAW SOME
KIND OF OBJECT CRASH LAND.
IT WAS INSPECTED BY LOCALS.
THERE WERE BEING INSIDE AND IT
WAS CARTED AWAY BY THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT.
PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO BE CALLED
CRAZY SO NO ONE SAID A LOT
ABOUT.
PEOPLE IN THE U.S. GOVERNMENT
BELIEVE IT'S TRUE AND THIS WEEK
THE DEFENSE DEPARTMENT SPENDING
BILL WILL REQUIRE AS PER
CONGRESS TO INVESTIGATE WHAT
REALLY HAPPENED.
NICK POPE IS A FORMER MINISTRY
DEFENSE OFFICIAL.
THIS IS A STORY THAT MOST
AMERICANS ARE NOT AWARE OF.
CLEARLY PEOPLE WITHIN THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT BELIEVE IT'S REAL OR
THEY WOULD NOT HAVE ATTACHED
THIS TO A SPENDING BILL,
CORRECT?
>> YES.
YOU ARE RIGHT.
PEOPLE WITH AND KNOWLEDGE EVER
THESE INTELLIGENCE PROGRAMS
PEOPLE MADE SURE THERE WAS PUT
INTO THE LEGISLATION.
IT'S ONE OF MANY UFO PROVISIONS
IN THE NEW DEFENSE BILL.
THE DOD MUST PROVIDE CONGRESS
WITH A LIST OF EVERYTHING THEY
FOUND OUT ABOUT THIS AND ALL
OTHER INCIDENTS AND PROGRAMS
FROM JANUARY 1, 1945 ONWARD.
ANYONE INVOLVED WILL BE RELEASED
FROM THEIR SECRECY OATHS AND CAN
TESTIFY TO CONGRESS ABOUT THIS.
>> Tucker: WE HAVE A NUCLEAR
CONNECTION AGAIN.
THE FIRST DETONATION OF
A NUCLEAR DEVICE.
YOU HAD UFO SIGHTINGS AROUND
NUCLEAR SUBMARINES.
NUCLEAR HAS SOME CONNECTION TO
THESE SIGHTINGS?
>> THAT SEEMS TO BE THE CASE.
CONGRESS IS DEMANDING ANSWERS ON
THIS.
WE HAVE THE REPORT FROM THE
DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE THAT HIGHLIGHTED
THE FACT THERE WERE SEVERAL
HUNDRED MORE SIGHTINGS BEING
INVESTIGATED.
IT TALKED ABOUT UNUSUAL FLIGHT
CHARACTERISTICS.
WE MUST GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
THIS UFO AND NUCLEAR CONNECTION.
>>